the numbers are in for Sunday night's
Golden Globes yeah an eighteen point six
million people tuned in slightly down
from last year but they did see a jump
in viewers in the coveted 18 to 49
category and as we know well a star is
born was nearly shutout at the globe's
but their family reunion continued at
Sam Elliott's handprint ceremony
yesterday I've got no problem telling
you Sam just how much I love and admire
you
Bradley I'd say it's safe to say that
the reason I'm here is because you were
filmed and I love YouTube
the emotions were on full display as
both Bradley and Lady gaga came to see a
star cemented into Hollywood Gaga was
dressed in a chic blue trench coat that
was a similar hue to her Golden Globes
gown and back on the carpet is where the
stars joy does form oh it's toast fir
caws cheers for the 10th year in a row
the official champagne of the Globes
will donate $1,000 to a charity of a
celebrities choice whatever charity you
would like MOA
will give them $1,000 I'd love if they
would make a contribution to the child
mind Institute I'm gonna toast to my
door as charity she's working with
Sivaji P Henson on mental health thank
you for this I'd like to cheer towards
the Legal Defense Fund
hashtag times up times to CTA Oh P my
yeah Africa outreach project
special needs from so what charity would
you like us to donate and toast to
tonight well seeing as how I'm
representing Freddie Mercury this
evening let's do the mercury Phoenix
trust I love that boy does this I think
it's awesome and over the 10 years we'll
toast four causes raised by the two
hundred fifty thousand dollars for two
hundred charities
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]